we're Trump supporters a monolithic
group of people with identical opinions
the democracy fund voter study group
recently looked at the data and dr.
Emily Eakins identified five separate
clusters of his supporters strong
conservatives were the largest group
these people are loyal Republicans solid
fiscal conservatives and have
traditional values a second group of his
supporters free marketeers favors
smaller government have moderate to
liberal social views and support free
trade the third group are what Eakins
called the anti elites
these people are more progressive and
see the economic and political system
stacked against them still another group
that disengaged are only about 5% of his
supporters a final group what Eakins
called the American preservationist
might be the most significant for Trump
because they propelled him to the
nomination they support higher taxes on
the rich like the social safety net and
a free trade sceptics there is overlap
among the groups but the big takeaway
from Eakins analysis is that there is no
such thing as a single kind of Trump
voting to learn more about my take on
the different kinds of Trump voters
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you
want our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI